WE'D LIKE TO TAKE CARE OF SOME
HOUSEKEEPING BEFORE WE GET INTO
TODAY'S AGENDA IT OF COURSE
WELCOME -- PROTEIN MACHEN'S
WHO'S HERE TODAY ALONG WITH
TREASURE MON WE WELCOME.
BOTH TO COMMITTEE WE HAVE ONE
ITEM ON OUR CONSENT COUNTER AND
THAT'S S. B.
TWO FORTY TWO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO DO A QUICK PREVIEW OF THE
ROAD AHEAD OVER THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS FOR COMMITTEE.
APRIL TENTH IS GOING TO BE A
HEAVY MEETING -- TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY THREE BILLS APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH WE'LL HAVE A SPECIAL
START TIME AT NINE AM BECAUSE OF
WORKLOAD THIS CAN BE COMING IN
WE WILL ALSO HAVE A SPECIAL
ORDER HEARING.
ON TWO BILLS SP FOUR NSP --
FIFTY AND I WILL GUARANTEE YOU --
THAT HEARING WILL BE MEETING AND
THEN ON A POLE -- AND THEN ON
MAY FIRST WE HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS --
IN COMING INTO COMMITTEE AS WELL
THE VICE CHAIR IS FIRED UP AND
READY TO GO -- AND HAS HIS COPY
UP FOR THOSE MEETINGS.
THEY GENERALLY LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM -- AS SOON AS
WE HAVE -- FOR MEMBERS HERE
WITHOUT FURTHER DO WE LIKE TO BE
A TURN IT OVER TO THE HARDEST
WORKING PROTEIN.
AND THAT'S SENATOR ACTIONS ON SP.
FOUR FIFTY ONE BUT IN CENTER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND WE WELCOME
YOU.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MR VICE CHAIRMAN.
I'M THRILLED TO BE HERE THANK
YOU FOR THE COURTESY OF LETTING
ME GO FIRST I'M CERTAINLY GLAD
I'M NOT HERE.
LATER IN THE MONTH.
HI I'M I'M REALLY PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT -- SENATE BILL
FOUR FIFTY ONE THIS MEASURE
WOULD CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A TAX CREDIT
FOR THE PRESERVATION.
AND REHABILITATION OF HISTORIC
BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF ENACTED CALIFORNIA WOULD JOIN
THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES WITH
STATE HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS.
A STATE HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
WOULD HELP TO STIMULATE LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND REVITALIZE
DOWNTOWN AREAS.
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE IN THIS
MEASURE ESTABLISHES ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA.
THAT ENSURE IT WILL ALSO.
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- SUPPORT
SMART GROWTH THROUGH INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND ENCOURAGE
PROPERTY MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION IN ECONOMICALLY
DEPRESSED AREAS TAX CREDITS A
PROVEN TO WORK IN ALL OF THESE
CASES AND WE CAN GIVE YOU.
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE OF
SUCCESSFUL PROJECTS THAT SHOW
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
SP FOUR FIFTY ONE I IS CAREFULLY
CONSTRUCTED TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY BUT TASKING THE
OFFICE OF HISTORIC PRESERVATION
AND THE TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE HOUSE IN OUR
TREASURER'S OFFICE. TO ENSURE
THAT ONLY DESERVING PROJECTS
WILL BE AWARDED THE TAX CREDIT.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL CONTAINS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
LA -- AND THE ANNUAL AGGREGATE
CAP OF FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FIVE YEARS.
BY ENABLING CALIFORNIANS TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL REHABILITATION
TAX CREDITS IT'S OUR HOPE THAT
THIS MEASURE WILL PROVIDE THE
EXTRA INCENTIVE NECESSARY TO
STIMULATE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS.
WHILE ALSO BUILDING ON CIVIC
PRIDE AS WE CELEBRATE OUR
HERITAGE AND PRESERVE
CALIFORNIA'S PAST.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN --
AND CERTAINLY COMMITTEE STAFFER
IDENTIFYING SOME AMENDMENTS
REFLECTED -- IN COMMENTS FIVE AN
AIDE IN THE ANALYSIS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
TODAY BUT I WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIRMAN.
ON ISSUES RELATED TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS -- A AND I KNOW I
TO JOIN THE CHAIRMAN IN WANTING
TO VERY NARROWLY DEFINED THIS
BECAUSE I THINK HOMEOWNERS --
YOU SHOULD BE REVIEWED VERY
CAREFULLY -- BUT I DO KNOW THAT
THAT THERE ARE OWNERS OF
HISTORIC HOMES THAT WERE ABLE TO
PURCHASE THEIR HOMES.
IN TIMES WHEN CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING MARKET IS NOT WHAT IT IS
TODAY I CAN POINT TO EXAMPLES OF
HOMES.
IN MY COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO
THERE PART OF HISTORIC DISTRICTS
BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT ONE HOUSE
THAT OBVIOUSLY SOMEBODY BOUGHT
IT DECADES AGO AND THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROTECT THE
HISTORICITY OF THAT HOME.
I WOULD LIKE NARROWLY DEFINED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE HOME
OWNERS. TO NOT -- CONTRIBUTE TO
OR TOWARDS THE DEGRADATION OF A
DISTRICT SO IF WE CAN BETWEEN
NOW AND THE APPROPRIATIONS I
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIRMAN AND HIS
INCREDIBLE STAFF. TO MORE
NARROWLY DEFINED THAT FOR THE
PURPOSE -- THAT MEETS THE INTENT
OF OF THE YOU KNOW THE
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE IN THAT
AREA.
BUT WITH THAT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS I DO THINK THIS IS.
AN IMPORTANT PROJECT AND I'M
THRILLED TODAY TO SEE THAT OUR
STATE TREASURER -- FIONA MA IS
HERE TO TESTIFY ALONG WITH
SEVERAL OF THE OTHER FOLKS
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU AN
IMPORTANT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK -- WITH THE PRO TEAM IN HER
FANTASTIC TEAM ON THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT PORTION OF THE BILL AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF HER
WORK AND HER WILLINGNESS IS WELL.
I INFER ADVANCING THIS GREAT
BILL WE WELCOME MADAM TREASURE
TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU -- CENTER MCGUIRE AND
AND THEY'RE MORE LOCK UP HAPPY
TO BE HERE TO BE OF SERVICE TO
WORK WITH.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH -- PRESIDENT
PRO TEM ATKINS OUR OFFICE
ADMINISTERS THE NINE AND 4%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX CREDITS
AND THESE DAYS IT IS MORE AND
MORE.
ARE COSTLY TO DEVELOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- AND THE LINE THE LINE
FOR THE 9% AFFORDABLE TAX
CREDITS IS VERY VERY LONG AND WE
CAN'T ACCOMMODATE EVERYONE.
SO WE THINK THIS IDEA IS IS VERY
NOVEL IT AFFORDS MORE FOLKS TO
BE ABLE TO USE A STATE TAX
CREDIT PERHAPS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH.
OUR FEDERAL TAX CREDIT TO REHAB
AND PRESERVE THESE HISTORIC
BUILDING SO IT WOULD.
GO A LONG WAY I THINK TO
PRESERVING MANY OF THESE
BUILDINGS INTO A RE PURPOSED
THEM TO A HIGHER AND BEST USE
THAT MEETS TODAY'S CURRENT NEEDS.
TRICIA MY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
GOOD MORNING SIR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO TO TESTIFY -- I MEAN THAT
IS IT ON WITH -- DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AT THE CALL FOR A TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION IN AS THE TRIGGER
STATED -- WE ADMINISTER THE
FEDERAL AND STATE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
IT JUST WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
TO FILL FINANCING GAPS ON
PROJECTS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
OTHERWISE.
BE ABLE TO GET DONE SO.
I THINK THAT THE RESOURCE WOULD
BE HELD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- REGRETFULLY
HERE TODAY.
PLEASE EXAMINE WE NOW WOULD LIKE
TO BE AT OPENING UP FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
YOU STATE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME AS WELL AS YOUR POSITION.
FIRST MY SAME POSITION GOOD
MORNING MA'AM WELCOME COMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CINDY
HEIGHTS MAN.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANKS SENATE
PRO TEM MACHEN'S SADDAM
ACQUIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT
IS MY HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRESERVATION FOUNDATION I SEEK
YOUR SUPPORT OF S. BEFORE.
FIFTY ONE THE STORE BUILDINGS
REHABILITATION TAX CREDIT.
IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF OUR MOST
BELOVED LANDMARKS ARE RESTORED
AND USEFUL TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS HISTORIC
BUILDINGS REHABILITATED WITH NEW
USES.
ARE NOT ONLY IMPORTANT TO
MEETING HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS BUT
INCREASES OUR RESILIENCE.
IN THE FACE OF DISASTER.
A REHABILITATED BUILDING IS
TRANSFORMED FROM UNDER USE
UNDERPERFORMING BUILDING TO A
SAFER BUILDING BY APPROVING IT
SEISMIC RESISTANCE FAR
PROTECTIONS AND SYSTEMS
INFRASTRUCTURE WHILE PRESERVING
COMMUNITY CHARACTER AND FUSING
NEW ECONOMIC VITALITY INTO AN
AREA.
SOME FEATURES OF THIS BILL
INSURE THAT THE BILL IS
EQUITABLE. 5% BONUSES FOR
CERTAIN TYPES OF PROJECTS AND A
TEN MILLION DOLLARS SET ASIDE
FOR SMALL PROJECTS UNDER MILLION
DOLLARS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TO AN AVERAGE
OF TEN REHABILITATION PROJECTS
PER YEAR USE FEDERAL HISTORIC
TAX CREDITS IN CALIFORNIA.
FROM 200-022-00016 FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TAX CREDITS.
CATALYZED ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA TOTALING
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
IN QUALIFYING REHABILITATION
EXPENDITURES.
A CALIFORNIA START TAX CREDIT
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF HISTORIC BUILDING
REHABILITATION PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
HERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES FROM
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE A STATE
HISTORIC TAX CREDIT.
OUR RECORDS UNIVERSITY STUDY OF
THE KANSAS HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
FOUND THAT THE TWENTY ONE YEAR
PERIOD BEFORE THEIR STATE TAX
CREDIT WAS IN PLACE.
THERE WAS AN AVERAGE OF TWO
POINT FOUR FEDERAL HISTORIC TAX
CREDIT PROJECTS PER YEAR.
WITH AN AGGREGATE ONE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENT.
IN THE EIGHT YEARS FOLLOWING THE
ENACTMENT OF A HISTORIC STATE
TAX CREDIT CANCER SO A TOTAL OF
CREDIT PROJECTS.
COMPLETED OR AN AVERAGE OF SIXTY
EIGHT PER YEAR.
REPRESENTING IN AGGREGATE
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
BUILDING REHABILITATION.
THE STATE OF OKLAHOMA CITY STORE
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM ANNUAL REPORT
NOTES THAT QUOTE.
THE AVERAGE HISTORIC
REHABILITATION PROJECT HAS
QUADRUPLED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
OF THE TOTAL DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENT HAS INCREASED EIGHTY
TWO TIMES FROM JUST OVER ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN. TWO THOUSAND
FIVE TO EIGHTY FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE PROGRAM
HAS BEEN EXCEPTIONALLY
SUCCESSFUL INCREASING INVESTMENT
IN HISTORIC REHABILITATION AND
OKLAHOMA.
END QUOTE.
BEFORE ENACTMENT OF THEIR STATE
HISTORIC TAX CREDIT TEXAS
AVERAGE THREE PROJECTS PER YEAR.
BUT ACCORDING TO THIS TASK THIS
HISTORIC COMMISSION.
THE NEW HISTORIC TAX CREDIT HAS
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF PROJECTS QUALIFYING FOR THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS FOR EXAMPLE.
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVEN A TWENTY
YEAR PERIOD HOUSTON HAD FORTY
CERTIFIED HISTORIC TAX CREDITS
WITH THE TOTAL QUALIFIED
REHABILITATION EXPENDITURE IN
THE AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN MILLION.
SENSOR STATE HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
WENT INTO EFFECT IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN THEY HAVE TWELVE
ACTIVE PROJECTS THIS IS IN
HOUSTON ALONE.
BEING CERTIFIED FOR THE FEDERAL
TAX CREDIT WITH AN ESTIMATED
COST OF TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN
MILLION.
THESE REHABILITATION PROJECTS
WERE NOT HAPPENING WHICH IS THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
IT WAS ONLY THE COMBINATION OF
THE STATE AND FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM PROGRAM THAT MADE THESE
REHABILITATION PROJECTS
FINANCIALLY VIABLE.
I MUST NOTE THAT IN ADDITION TO
CALIFORNIA TENNESSEE A HAWAII.
ALSO HAVE TAX CREDIT BILLS
INTRODUCED IN THEIR LEGISLATURE
NOW.
EXPERIENCE FROM OTHER STATES
SHOW THAT SHORT TERM LOSS OF
STATE TAX REVENUE IS RECOVERED
IMMEDIATELY DURING CONSTRUCTION
AND FULLY WITHIN A MATTER OF
YEARS ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE
ECONOMIC ASSESSMENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE MARYLAND GOVERNOR'S
TASK FORCE FOUND THAT FOR EVERY
DOLLAR PAID OUT BY THE STATE.
THIRTY FOUR CENTS WAS RETURNED
DURING THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE.
IN OHIO CLEVELAND STATE
UNIVERSITY FOUND THAT THE OHIO
PROGRAM RECEIVED. THIRTY THREE
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED
BECAUSE THE TAXES ON
CONSTRUCTION LABOR MATERIALS.
FOR EVERY DOLLAR TAX CREDIT
AWARDED THE LOUISIANA TREASURY
RECEIVE FORTY TWO CENTS BEFORE
DEVELOPER OWNER CAN EVEN USE THE
CREDIT.
AND THE STUDY OF TWENTY FIVE
REHABILITATION PROJECTS
UNDERTAKEN IN WISCONSIN.
IN NIGHT TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
ESTIMATED THAT THE STATE WOULD
RECEIVE FORTY CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR DURING THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE. TO RECOVER THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT VARIES FROM NINE
YEARS AS REPORTED IN VIRGINIA TO
FOUR YEARS AS REPORTED IN
WISCONSIN.
THIS IS AFTER THE BUILDINGS ARE
PUT INTO SERVICE.
THINK OF STORE TAX CREDITS WILL
PRESERVE HISTORIC PLACES.
PROVIDE JOBS [inaudible]
INCREASE HOUSING.
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL VITALITY
TO ENSURE THAT OUR SHARED
HERITAGE.
IN JURORS FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO JOINING
THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES.
WHO HAVE SUCCESSFUL STATE
HISTORIC TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS AND
SEEK YOUR SUPPORT OF SB?
FOUR FIFTY ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ELOQUENT TESTIMONY WE WERE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE KNOW WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE SYSTEM YOUR
TESTIMONY TO FIRST AND LAST IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE TODAY GOOD MORNING
SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MARK
CHRISTIAN WITH THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
WE ASK FOR YOUR YES I VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS CHRISTIAN IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
THANK YOU TYLER MUNCIE ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES
CALIFORNIAN STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS FOR BEING YOUR TETHER
GOING TO SIR.
DUNGEONS CAN BE HAVE THE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS SAYS HIS
CALIFORNIAN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
THANKS TERRY THE CITIES OF LONG
BEACH IN ONTARIO IN SPORT THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WHO WOULD NOW LIKE TO BE ADDED
TO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT LAST CALL FOR THOSE
FOR AND SUPPORTED YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO MIKE FROM
THIS TIME?
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCED TO THE
FRONT TABLES AT THIS TIME ANYONE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ADVANCE?
LAST CALL.
ALL RIGHT THIS BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- AND WE WOULD ALSO
WELCOME A MOTION AS WELL.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
HERE HERE AND SEE NONE IS THERE
A MOTION ACCUSING WE'RE STILL A
SUBCOMMITTEE I APOLOGIZE GET A
LITTLE INTO TO BE A GOOD MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS.
A CENTER ACTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE AND WE'LL TAKE ACTION
ONCE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER PRO TIMBER VERY GRATEFUL.
SO WE WILL BE PUTTING THIS ASIDE
FOR THE TIME BEING AND IT WILL
TAKE ACTION ON THIS AS SOON AS
WE STEPPED YOUR CORN.
BETTER PROTEIN THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK ON THIS GREAT BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MAN TREASURE
INTO ALL OF OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
PLACE IN GENERAL WE NOW WOULD BE
A LIKE TO MOVE. TO FINAL ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS B..
FOURTEEN BUT WE'RE GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON MR GLAZER.
ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION BOND WE
WELCOME.
GOOD SENATOR FROM AROUND HERE.
WE DO KNOW THAT WE HAVE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT WE HAVE.
EMILY'S MOM WHO IS HERE TODAY WE
WELCOME -- IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
EMILY SAID PLEASE DO NOT SAY
THAT SO -- IN THE IN THE OFFICE
TODAY -- IN IT'S WONDERFUL TO
SEE YOU AND YOU HAVE DONE SUCH A
WONDERFUL JOB WITH YOUR DAUGHTER
I GOT TO TELL YOU -- GREAT JOB
AND WE'RE GONNA TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO SINNERS LASER -- WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT TODAY -- AND THEN WE
WILL OFFER FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO SPEAK AT THE MICROPHONE
SHORTLY.
MR GLACIERS FORESHORES THANK YOU
DEAR -- ACQUIRE WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS BILL IS JOINTLY AUTHORED BY
SENATOR ALAN HE IS CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE NOT ABLE TO BE WITH ME.
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH AND IT
IS A GOOD SURE LET YOU KNOW YOUR
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE
TODAY SO AND PLASTIC TO HEAR
THAT -- BY DOING EXCEPT THE
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED ON THE LAST PAGE OF THE
ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL WILL AUTHORIZE A
BILLION DOLLAR BOND FOR THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT. FOR
FACILITIES AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN MORE THAN A DECADE
SINCE CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO DEDICATE FUNDS TO
BUILD REPAIR HIGHER EDUCATION
CLASSROOMS RESEARCH LABS AND
LIBRARIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND NO HIGHER EDUCATION SPECIFIC
BOND HAS BEEN BEEN PLACED ON THE
BALLOT OR PASSED SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO ALL THE BOND
DOLLARS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE LAST
RECEIVED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
HAVE BEEN USED.
AND PROJECTS ARE BEING SIDELINED
AT THE CSU AND THESE C..
AS THEY WORK HARD TO MAINTAIN
OLD BUILDINGS AND FACILITIES.
I KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THAT IN THEIR OWN
TESTIMONY WHAT WE'RE GONNA HERE
IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
SO WITH THAT SIDE THE BILL HAS
BROAD SUPPORT AND I'D THANK YOU
FOR YOUR POSITIVE CONSIDERATION
TODAY.
IN SUMMER SOONER LASER VERY
GRATEFUL UP FOR YOU WORK ON THIS
THIS IS BEING -- PASSION A
SINNER GLASER'S FOR MANY YEARS
NOW IN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOUR EFFORT.
WE WERE JUST INFORMED THAT WE
MAY NOT HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO HAVE A ROBUST
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY BUT
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHO'D LIKE TO BE ONE OF OUR TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TODAY.
I'M HAPPILY OFF IF THAT'S OKAY
CENTER PLEASE GOOD MORNING --
JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WELL TO BE HERE TODAY AS A CO
SPONSOR ALONG WITH THE COMFORT
THAT UNIVERSITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD
ALSO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THE TRAFFIC
ANALYSIS THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU TODAY -- CLEARLY THE NEEDS
WITHIN UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA ARE
GREAT -- OUR FIVE YEAR CAPITAL
FINANCIAL PLAN HAS IDENTIFIED --
ELEVEN POINT FIVE ELEVEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION SORRY IN SYSTEM
WHY NEEDS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA THESE ARE NEEDS THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE OUR GROWING STUDENT
POPULATION.
ADDRESS OF RENEWAL SEISMIC IN A
VARIETY OF OTHER DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS -- WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE GONNA BE
REQUIRED IN ORDER FOR THE VERSA
CALIFORNIA TO GET YOU TO SERVE
THE STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE.
IN IT'S THE TIME I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE I HAVE A COLLEAGUE
HERE DUCKS SIMPSON FROM OUR
CAPITAL FACILITIES.
AVAILABLE TO ASK ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE -- BUT
WILL DEFER TO OUR COLLEAGUE THIS
ISSUE THIS TIME VERY GRATEFUL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
pCOMMITTEE MORNING MARY MORE OIL
WITH THE CSU FOR ALSO PLEASED TO
BE -- SPOT SPONSORING THIS BILL
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR GLAZER AND
LIKE -- COMMITTEE STAFF.
TO AS THE AUTHOR SAID OUR CAMP
CAMPUSES ARE IN GREAT NEED OF
ASSISTANCE WITH THEIR FACILITIES.
MORE THAN HALF OF CS USE
FACILITY SPACES OVER FORTY YEARS
YEARS OLD AND THE THIRD IS OVER
FIFTY YEARS OLD.
THIS MEANS THAT OUR CAN'T
CAMPUSES CAN EXPERIENCE
CHALLENGES SUCH AS POWER OUTAGES
WHICH FOURTH CLASS DB.
CAMP CANCELED OR HAVE A LACK OF
DEPENDABLE INTERNET.
THE FOUR BILLION DOLLAR SHARE
THE BOND FOR CS YOU WOULD HELP
US TO ADDRESS DEFICIENCIES IN
OUR OLDER BUILT BUILDINGS.
AND PROVIDE SAFE AND RELIABLE
FACILITIES WHERE STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF CAN LEARN TO
TEACH AND AND WORK.
IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW US TO
MODERNIZE OUR CLASSROOM SPACE TO
KEEP UP WITH CURRENT WORK WORK
FORCE TRENDS.
FINALLY IT WOULD ALLOW US TO
GROW OUR CAMP CAMPUSES SO THAT
WE COULD SERVE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS.
AND WE ALSO BROUGHT IN EXPERT
WHICH WITNESS BY BY TEN ONE FOR
MORE CAPITAL FACILITIES DIVISION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
SURVEYS ARE WE'D LIKE TO BETTER
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AT THAT WORKS
FOR YOU AND THEN ALSO I TAKE A
VOTE ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR IS
WELL -- IF THAT WORKS YOU'RE NOT
TRYING TO BE RUDE BUT BEFORE WE
GO TO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITH
ACTIVATED TAKE A TWENTY SECOND
PIES SO I CAN GET MY INFORMATION
WITH MISS MANCHESTER IN MOURNING.
I DO A ROLL CALL
.
WHERE DID YOU GET ON THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO ESTABLISH A CORN MISALIGNED
CHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL?
WARRIOR HERE WHY PRESIDENT
MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE PRESIDENT BELL.
BELL PRESIDENT KURTZ BURKE FOR
TARO YELTSIN WINNER.
WE ARE PRESENT.
YEAH HOW GOOD.
WE HAVE FOUR MEMBERS PRESENT TO
IF IT WORKS FOR THE MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TAKE A QUICK
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE
HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR
THIS IS ON ESPY TWO FOUR TO IT
TO DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS --
MISALIGNED CHESTER ROLL CALL
PLEASE WIRE HI WHERE I'M MORE A
LOTMORE LIKE I BAILED.
ON HERTZ BURKE FOR TOMORROW
[inaudible]
NELSON WINNER.
WE ARE.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN WE'RE GONNA TAKE A QUICK
ROLL CALL AN S. B.. FOUR FIVE
ONE ATKINS THIS IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS WE HAVE
A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
MISS LANE CHESTER ROLL CALL
PLEASE WIRE HI WHY I'M MORE LONG.
DELL.
DELL I HEARD SOBER FOR TOTAL
BILL SINCE WE WE ARE I CURRENTLY
GEORGIA THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN WE'RE
NOW GOING TO OPEN UP. TO ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMIT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE.
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST IN
THE ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE
WITH WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
INCONVENIENCE OF DOING SOME OF
THAT HOUSEKEEPING THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU'RE HAVING A BUSY
MORNING TODAY.
AS YOU WERE JUST IN EDUCATION
WELCOME SIR THANK YOU -- GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS A NURSE I
THINK HAVING A SECOND YEAR
STUDENT UCLA AND ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
WHEN I FIRST TOOK MY FINAL EXAMS
TWO WEEKS AGO I SAW THE ALL TOO
COMMON SIDE OF STUDENTS TAKING
TESTS IN OVERCROWDED LECTURE
HALLS WITH BROKEN DESKS AND
CHAIRS?
I'M ALSO REMINDED OF WEEKS
EARLIER WHEN RAINS FLOODED THE
FINANCIALLY AND COUNSELING
OFFICES CLASSROOMS AND LABS AT
UCLA UC IRVINE AND UC DAVIS
AMONG OTHERS.
AND JUST YESTERDAY DURING MY
FIRST DAY OF CLASS I SAW THE
FEAR IN MY PROFESSOR'S EYES AS
SHE EXPLAINED OUR UNIVERSITIES
ACTIVE SHOOTER POLICIES.
ONLY TO REALIZE THAT SHE COULD
NOT FOLLOW AT SINCE THE DOORS IN
OUR OLD LECTURE HALL COULDN'T BE
LOCKED FROM THE INSIDE.
WHEN ME AND MY CLASSMATES WHO
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE KNEE ON
THE GROUND WE CAN'T HELP BUT SEE
A STATE THAT DOESN'T INVEST IN
OUR SPACES -- BUT IN SB FOURTEEN
WE SEE A PROMISING FUTURE A
THIRTEEN YEAR OVERDUE MASS
REINVESTMENT IN OUR SPACES AND
ULTIMATELY EVER OUT MASS
REINVESTMENT IN OUR STUDENTS.
THE UCC ASSOCIATION THE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
WE FIRST THAT REPRESENT HAVE
MADE THIS ONE OF OUR TOP FIVE
PRIORITIES AND LOOK FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN BY FUNDING OUR
FACILITIES YOUR FUNDING OUR
FUTURE PLEASE SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU.
HOW MUCH MAKING A TRACK AS WELL
GOOD MORNING SIR MY GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS OUR MONDO LAMB
CURRENTLY AT THIRTY YEAR
UNDERGRADUATE AT UCLA?
AND WE TRAVELED REALLY EARLY
FROM THE FOUNDERS LOS ANGELES TO
SHORE SUPPORT FOR A THREE FORTY
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOVERNMENTS WERE GRATEFUL GOOD
MORNING SIR.
MY NAMES CONOR PHASE I'M ALSO A
PART OF THE UCLA UNDERGRADS
WHOSE UNDERGRADUATE SOCIAIS SHIN
I'M VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN THE REMOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING TIME IS
SCHEDULED TO BE HERE GOOD
MORNING MA'AM THE MORNING I HAD
A BAD START WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE ARE GRATEFUL.
WE'D LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
HERE IN SCENE AND WE NOW LIKE TO
WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL TO PLEASE
ADVANCE THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE NOW LIKE YOU BETTER BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR CONVERSATION. TO ANY
QUESTIONS OUR CONVERSATION OR
EMOTION WE HAVE CENTER BELL.
AT MY SCHOOL ARRIVE ALUMNI OF
THIS OUT OF THE STATE -- THERE
IS A HUGE PROBLEM WITH HOMELESS
STUDENTS -- WHEN I TALK TO OTHER
CAMPUSES AROUND THE STATE?
A SIMILAR PROBLEM.
I THINK TO CLOSE OUR EYES AND
NOR THIS.
ANYMORE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- A BOND IS GOING ON THE
BALLOT TO IMPROVE FACILITIES.
WITHOUT DEALING WITH -- THE
SUBJECT MATTER OF HOMELESS OF
STUDENTS [inaudible]
OF IT I THINK IT HAS TO BE
INCLUDED SOMEHOW -- I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT PEOPLE'S THOUGHTS ARE
ABOUT.
WHAT'S GOING ON TO HELP THE
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND SHOULD WE
INCLUDE.
IN THIS BOND -- OKAY YOU KNOW
JUST -- ELIGIBLE ACTIVITY.
IT IT DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY SAY
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS AND FACULTY
BUT QUITE FRANKLY AND SOUNDS A
AND PROBABLY OTHER AREAS -- YOU
HAVE THE HOUSING.
PEOPLE RIGHT HERE ON THE
COMMITTEE WAS CENTER WINNERS
CENTER CHOIR MYSELF [inaudible]
OF CAN YOU TELL US WHAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO DO.
WITH THIS BOND I THINK THE BAR
WOULD BE MORE ATTRACTIVE.
IF IT PROVIDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS BECAUSE
QUITE FRANKLY WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE STUDENTS.
IS IF THEY DON'T HAVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT AND BORROW
MONEY TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
LIVING EXPENSES.
AND THAT JUST GOING OUT AND
GETTING A LOAN AND IT -- I FIND
AMOUNT OF STUDENT LOANS IN THIS
COUNTRY SHAMEFUL.
THERE WERE NOT SUPPORTING THE
OUR STUDENTS BETTER [inaudible]
WITH -- EDUCATION THAT'S
AFFORDABLE SO.
THE HOUSING COST IS -- PART OF
THE BIG PART OF THAT.
SO COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
I REMEMBER HOW HARD IT WAS
[inaudible] FOR MYSELF.
WORKINGAS A STUDENT IN -- IN A
FINE IN THE FIGHT WITH FINANCIAL
AID AS A STUDENT MYSELF WITH
FINANCIAL AID -- PAYING MY WAY
THROUGH SCHOOL.
AND TRYING TO FIND HOUSING
THAT'S AFFORDABLE FOR THE
STUDENTS -- AND I ACTUALLY
BECAME THE STUDENT HOUSING
COORDINATOR AT SAN JOSE STATE.
THAT WAS MY FIRST AREA OF
INTEREST IN POLITICS.
OF SO I I I I DON'T HONESTLY
HAVE A VERY SINCERE [inaudible]
BELIEVE THAT.
IT'S TIME TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS IN A BIGGER WAY SO.
YOU'RE YOU'RE THE ONES THAT CAN
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE I WANT TO
HEAR.
MOVIES CENTER GLAZIERS -- NASDAQ
AS THE SAN DIEGO STATE -- MAN SO
I LIKE TO HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THIS DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER THOUGHTS ON THIS SUBJECT.
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
THAT WAS SENATOR ABOUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR QUESTION AND
CERTAINLY -- THERE'S A FEW
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AT
WHO'S BEEN IT.
AS AN ARTICULATE AND ENERGETIC
LEADERS YOU HAVE BEEN ON THIS
ISSUE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT.
THAT WHAT ARE SOO STUDENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING A NOW -- AT SO MANY
OF OUR CAMPUSES IS -- IS THIS IS
MORE THAN UNCOMFORTABLE IT'S
IT'S UPSETTING.
AND IT'S DISAPPOINTING I EAT AND
WE BOTH KNOW THIS S A MUCH
BROADER ISSUE THAN SOMETHING
THAT THE UNIVERSITY -- HAS
CREATED ON ITS OWN IT'S A
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THAT WE WE SEE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATED AT EVERY
LEVEL A LITTLE AT THE SEGMENTS
TALK ABOUT IT IN REGARD TO THEIR
PARTICULAR -- AUTHORIZATION
OTHER OR THE LIKE -- I AM I AM A
VERY OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT I HAD NO ONE HAS RAISED
IT BEFORE -- AND I WOULD WELCOME
THE THE CONVERSATION I'D LIKE TO
DEFER TO BITE THE SEGMENTS TO
ADDRESS IT AS THEY AS THEY SEE
FIT AS WELL.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THE FIRST A
CRACK AT CENTER THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION VERY MUCH AND
CLEARLY -- WHETHER IT'S AUSTIN
HOMELESSNESS OR STUDENT FOOD
INSECURITY -- YOU KNOW THE
UNIVERSITY IS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THESE ISSUES AS THE IMPACT
OUR STUDENTS.
I WOULD SAY THAT ON THE THE
ISSUE OF FOOD SECURITY THE
UNIVERSITY IS -- WORKING VERY
HARD TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THERE TO BE FOOD PANTRIES
AND THE LIKE SO THAT THE BASIC
NEEDS CAN BE MET FOR STUDENTS.
I KNOW -- COLLEAGUES IN MY
OFFICE OR WORKING WITH MEMBERS
LIKE SENATOR DODD THIS YEAR ON
EFFORTS THAT WOULD EXPAND -- CAL
FRESH BENEFITS TO THE STUDENTS
AND SO FORTH SO THERE ARE
ONGOING ACTIVITIES IN THAT
RESPECT WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING.
I HAD MENTIONED THAT -- NEAR THE
UNIVERSITY IS ABLE TO BORROW NOW --
FOR A STUDENT HOUSING AND THE
PRESENT APARTADO HAS STATED THAT
HER GOAL TO HAVE THE UNIVERSITY
AT THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL BEDS
ON CAMPUS SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO BE
ENROLLED IN AND HOUSED ON CAMPUS
THAT THEY'RE NOT COMPETING FOR
THOSE LIMITED SPACES THAT ARE
YOU KNOW COMING IN AT THE HIGHER
AND HIGHER LEVELS.
OUTSIDE THE CAMPUS -- BUT BUT
THOSE ABILITY THE ABILITY TO
BUILD THOSE PROJECTS IS OF A
MARK IN OUR MIND SEPARATE
INSTINCT FROM.
THE TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WITH REGARD -- TO
THE BOND THAT WE'RE BRINGING
FORWARD TODAY NO NO -- JUST
RESPOND TO THAT.
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE STUDIED THE
HOUSING ISSUE OF ON THE CAMPUS
IS PRETTY CLOSELY IN -- THE AND
I DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU HAVE.
A LIST OF HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO
LIVE ON THE ON CAMPUS HOUSING
[inaudible]
AROUND THE THE VARIOUS
UNIVERSITY THIS PUBLIC OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I KNOW IN -- SAN JOSE THAT --
THE RATE AT THE DORMITORY IS
LIKE SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
OR I MEAN MAYBE THE STUDENTS CAN
TELL US SOME OF THOSE THINGS BUT
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU THERE'S BEEN
A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY.
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING HERE IS THIS
JUST BORROWING MONEY A BUILDING
HOUSING THAT'S NOT ENOUGH YOU
HAVE TO SUBSIDIZE THE HOUSING TO
KEEP TO DOUBLE THE COSTS DOWN.
THE COST HAS TO GO DOWN IT'S TOO
HIGH RIGHT NOW EVEN THE ON
CAMPUS HOUSING IS WAY TOO HIGH
[inaudible]
SO.
THE QUESTION IS.
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO BUILD?
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS.
WHAT WITH THE STUDENTS THANK
WOULD BE AN AFFORDABLE LEVEL FOR
HOUSING?
IS THERE -- YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT.
ARE LITERALLY.
BORROWING MONEY TO PAY YOU FOR
THE STUDENT HOUSING -- BUILDING.
THERE'S SOME WRONG WITHOUT SAY
[inaudible]
WHY NOT?
WHY NOT HAVE US FUN?
THE SERVICE IS SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS.
AND BUILD THE STUDENT HOUSING
AND THEN -- LOWER THE COSTS THE
SOON SO DON'T HAVE TO BORROW THE
MONEY.
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR LIVING
EXPENSES.
SO SO IT WE NEED SOME MAGIC
THOUGHTS HERE I MEAN -- ALL WORK
WITH I'M I'M I'M SO HAPPY THAT
CENTER GLAZIERS -- INTERESTED IN
THIS HE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
I WILL MAYBE SOME OF THE OTHERS
COULD COMMENT.
IF I IF I MAY YOUR MIND IS
INTRODUCING YOURSELF PLEASE
REALLY FIVE SEVEN ONE ASSISTANT
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR CAPITAL
PLANNING DESIGNING INSTRUCTION
FOR THE ISSUE.
SO WE W WE'RE JUST ON THE FRONT
END OF OF LOOKING AT AT THIS
ISSUE NOT ONLY DOES THIS IS YOU
HAVE A BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVE.
BUT WE HAVE APPROACHED THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL TRYING
TO LOOK AT GRANT FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO THE CHALLENGE WAS OUR
STUDENTS IT WAS GETTING
TECHNICAL AS FAR AS CATEGORIES
HERS ATION BUT OUR STUDENTS
DIDN'T QUALIFY BECAUSE THEY ARE
TRANSIENT.
BUT WE DID TRY TO LOOK AT GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT THERE WE
COULD.
REALLY GET DOLLARS FOR CAPITAL
COSTS.
OTHERWISE WE HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
DEBT TO BUILD THE STUDENT
HOUSING RIGHT SO EVEN IF WE
BUILD NEW STUDENT HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS AND HAD USE OUR
EXISTING HOUSING. FOR THE
HOMELESS THERE'S STILL THE
OPERATIONAL COST AND WHETHER
THERE ARE FUNDS THAT COULD HELP
THE THOSE STUDENTS WITH.
NOT JUST THE CAPITAL COST BUT
THE OPERATING COSTS TO BE IN THE
DORMSFOR MEAL PLANS FOR EXAMPLE.
SO IT IS A COMPLEX ISSUE WE DID
MEET WITH THE FORMER CITY
MANAGERS OF IRVINE TRYING TO
TALK WITH THEM ABOUT HOW CAN SEE
THIS YOU PARTNER WITH CITIES TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THE REALLY STILL ON THE FRONT
END BUT APPRECIATE THE COMMON IN
AND RECOGNIZE THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING.
CERTAINLY THE BAY AREA BUT IN
SAN JOSE -- JUST SAY THIS -- RUN
SO SAM CISCO POSSIBLY.
HOUSING PROBLEMS FOR THE
STUDENTS OF IMMENSE YOU KNOW
THESE KOSTER SO.
BERKELEY ALL THE YOU CAN GO ON
AND ON UCLA -- THE COST IS SO
IMMENSE THAT WE HAVE.
TO WE HAVE TO HAVE THE MONTHLY
PAYMENT THAT STUDENTS MAY A LOT
LOWER.
AND THE TRADITIONAL COLLEGE
HOUSING FINANCING.
SYSTEM DOESN'T WORK ANYMORE.
IT ONLY WORKS FOR PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THAT.
HIGH INCOME OR CAL GRANTS THERE
IS LIKE A CAL GRANT MONEY IS
GOING TO THIS.
SO IF WE CAN LOWER THE COST OF
THE STUDENT HOUSING MORE.
MONEY WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
STUDENTS TO GET CALCRAFT FOR
EXAMPLE SO.
SO IT YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT IN A BIGGER [inaudible]
PITCHER -- AND IT REQUIRES
SUBSIDY GRANTS MONEY TO DRAW
DOWN THE COST OF THE FINANCING.
OF LEVERAGING FEDERAL DOLLARS --
THE USUAL WAY WE WORK WITH.
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE UNIVERSITY'S HASSOUN BRACE
THAT. TO LOWER THE COST YOU CAN
YOU KNOW I LIKE I KNOW ONE
HOUSING.
BECAUSE WE SPOKE ABOUT IT IN OUR
COMMITTEE THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
SOME REQUIRE NINE SO THAT WE
HEARD YESTERDAY AT A HOURS LONG
DISCUSSION MORE LOCAL SO.
IF YOU PUT UP ONE DOLLAR YOU GET
THREE DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TAX
THREE DOLLARS OF THE FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT SYSTEM.
SO IS THE BOND POSSIBLY COULD BE
LEVERAGING THE SOME KIND OF
FEDERAL.
MIX OF FUNDS.
TO FACILITATE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT WOULD LOWER THE
COST. FOR THE STUDENTS SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GO OUT AND BORROW
SO MUCH MONEY.
IN A WAIT WAIT WE JUST THE
BORROWING IS A SHAMEFUL THING IN
MY OPINION I MEAN IT'S LIKE.
IS A DISGRACE THAT WE HAVE OUR
STUDENTS BARRING SO MUCH MONEY.
I CENTER A CHOIR IF I COULD MAKE
AS A RESPONSE BECAUSE I SENATOR
BILL I I I THINK YOU WERE
RAISING AT AN IMPORTANT WEAKNESS --
THAT.
CROSSES A LOT OF DIFFERENT
SUBJECT AREAS IN REGARD TO OUR
UNIVERSITIES -- AND THAT IS THAT
THERE'S A PERCEPTION THAT
THEY'RE OUT THERE -- ISLANDS.
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT ADD THERE'S
NO INTEGRATION IN OUR BROADER
COMMUNITY ON THINGS LIKE HUNGER --
THINGS LIKE -- MENTAL ILLNESS
THINGS LIKE HOUSING AND THAT WE
HAVE KIND OF TRY TO ADDRESS
THESE PROBLEMS.
IN SILOS WHERE THE CAMPUSES ARE
EVEN IN THE EQUATION YOU AND I
HAVE BOTH WORKED ON A NUMBER OF
FORCIBLE HOUSING MINES IN OUR
STATE AND I CAN REMEMBER IN MY
EXPERIENCE.
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT STUDENT
HOUSING?
AS A PART OF THAT THE SUBSIDIES
THAT ARE REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
MAKE IT.
WORK -- FOR PEOPLE OF OF LOW
MEANS INCLUDING STUDENTS AND
THAT'S THAT'S AN OMISSION.
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT BECAUSE
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS HOW
WE INCORPORATE.
THE CAMPUS COMMUNITY WITH ALL
THEIR NEEDS INTO THE BROADER
COMMUNITY BCAUSE YOU AND I BOTH
KNOW THAT.
THAT THIS ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY
AND HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE ACROSS
THE BOARD IT'S ALL OVER THE
STATE IN EVERY EVERY PART OF THE
STATE.
AND STUDENTS CERTAINLY
EXPERIENCE THAT -- IN AN EGG TO
A GREAT EXTENT AS WELL SO.
I THINK YOU'VE GRAZED IMPORTANT
SENSITIVITY I DON'T KNOW IF.
THERE IS A WAY TO INCORPORATED
IN THIS FINE I'D LIKE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SEGMENTS
TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
AND YOU HAVE ENERGIZE ME TO TALK
ABOUT WITH YOU AND OTHERS ABOUT
HOW WE INCORPORATE THE STUDENT
COMMUNITY AND SOME OF OUR
BROADER.
SOCIAL WELFARE EFFORTS INCLUDING
SUBSIDIES -- IN THE AREA OF
HOUSING AND I APPRECIATE YOU
RAISING IT. TOO MUCH OF OUR MAY
I RESPOND QUICKLY PLEASE.
OKAY MY NAME IS DOUG STIMSON
EXACTED DIRECTOR OF CAP LOSSES
STRATEGIES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE THE PRESIDENT.
AND THE YOU SEE HAS TAKEN STRONG
EFFORTS AND AND AND WE'RE OPEN
TO DIFFERENT IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO
APPROACH THIS ISSUE IT IS A BIG
ISSUE FOR US.
EVERY REGENTS MEETING WE ARE
BRINGING HOUSING PROJECTS WE
JUST APPROVED THE REGION JUST
APPROVED OVER THREE THOUSAND
BEDS AT SANTA CRUZ.
AND THE DISCUSSION IS HOW CAN WE
MAKE THESE MORE AFFORDABLE AND
SOME OF THEM ARE GOING TO GO OUT
OF 50% OF MARKET.
SO WE ON AND ON EVERY SINGLE
PROJECT AND WE HAVE APPROVED
OVER TWELVE THOUSAND BEDS OVER
THE PAST THREE OR FOUR YEARS AND
WE HAVE ANOTHER TWENTY THOUSAND
THAT ARE IN THE PIPELINE AND SO%
ONE OF THOSE.
WAYS WERE RESPONDING IS REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
LEVERAGE OUR LAND.
AND BRING IN A HOUSING THAT IS
LESS THAN MARKET AND AS
AFFORDABLE AS WE CAN MAKE IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIMPSON.
A GOOD WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
VICE CHAIR.
THIS FEATURE -- I AM A
BENEFICIARY OF THE C. ISSUES
SYSTEM.
I'M A GRADUATE FROM LONG BEACH
STATE AND ACTUALLY A PROUD
ALUMNI OF THE YEAR BACK IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN COLLEGE OF
BUSINESS YEAH.
WE PICKED OUT OF SOME TWO
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
GRADUATES OF KIND OF A BIG DEAL --
BUT WHAT THIS DISCUSSION IS
MEETING MISSING.
IS OPPOSITION THE SENATOR GLAZER
I'M HERE TO PROVIDE THAT FOR
THIS MORNING IF I IF I COULD --
THIS WILL BE PAID OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND I'M ASSUMING ON A
BILLION DOLLAR BOND IS GOING TO
COST IN EXCESS OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION A YEAR AND PRINCIPAL AND
INTEREST.
AND SO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
WHERE THAT COMES FROM WHAT THAT
PUSHES OUT -- OR WHAT HOW DO WE
RAISE REVENUES RIGHT NOW --
BECAUSE I AM AN ACCOUNTING
PICTURE I DO READ THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS NOT ONLY FOR CALIFORNIA
BUT FOR THE REST OF THE STATES.
AND CALIFORNIA IS NOT IN GOOD
SHAPE COMPARED TO OUR
CONTEMPORARIES -- WE HAVE THE
LARGEST UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT
IN THE NATION -- IF WE DIVIDED
BY POPULATION -- FORTUNY WERE
ONLY IN FORTY SECOND PLACE BUT
WE WERE IN FORTY SIX PLACE WHEN
I FIRST CAME UP HERE SORT WE'RE
IMPROVING A LITTLE BIT.
OF BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE A MUCH
STRONGER BALANCE SHEET BEFORE WE
GO OUT.
THE ISSUE MORE DEBT I I JUST%
DON'T SEE HOW A FAMILY THAT'S
STRUGGLING WITH.
BUY A NEW CAR THAT IS WELL
BEYOND THEIR MEANS -- AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PUT THE CAR
PAYMENT IN THE MIX.
I I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
GET ON THE STRATEGY FINANCIALLY
THAT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'RE
REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO DO.
AND THAT IS WE SET ASIDE A
LITTLE BIT EVERY MONTH.
EVERY YEAR AND BUILD OUR
RESERVES AND THEN PAY FOR CASH
YOU WOULD PAY.
A WHOLE LOT LESS YOU SAVE 50% IF
WE PAID CASH AND AND WERE
DISCIPLINED.
IN THAT REGARD ANOTHER CONCERN I
HAVE IS THAT. FOR THE LAST SIXTY
YEARS AN INVERTED YIELD CURVE
HAS BEEN A PRETTY ACCURATE
PREDICTOR OF AN ONCOMING
RECESSION.
AND WE ARE NOW IN THAT TERRITORY
AGAIN WHERE WE HAVE.
AN INVERTED YIELD CURVE WHERE
THE SHORT END OF THE CURVE IS AT
THE SAME HEIGHT AS THE FOUR
THREE FOUR TEN YEAR BONDS.
SO WE'RE GETTING A GOOD SIGN.
AND JUST YOU KNOW IN THE END OF
THE INFORMATION WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
IN OUR PACKET.
WE DON'T FARE WELL COMPARED TO
OTHER STATES WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR RATING.
A CALIFORNIA IS NEAR THE BOTTOM
OUR OUR DEBT TO PERSONAL INCOME
IS THREE POINT 9% WHICH IS.
WELL OVER THE TWO POINT 3%
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
OUR DEBT PER CAPITA IS ALMOST
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WHICH IS
DOUBLE THE AVERAGE MORE THAN
DOUBLE.
IN OUR DEBT AS A PERCENTAGE OF
ST ST GDP IS ALSO ONE OF THE
HIGHEST.
YOU'LL SEE WERE NEAR THE BOTTOM
OF NEW YORK IN ILLINOIS.
AND ONE OF MY OVERALL THRUSTER
GOALS CENTER GLAZER IT IS IT
WHILE I'M HERE I WANT TO I DON'T
WANT TO BE ILLINOIS.
I WANNA MAKE SURE CALIFORNIA.
STRENGTHENS -- BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE DATA FOR
ILLINOIS IT'S IT'S MISERABLE.
AND I THINK WE HAVE THEM AS AN
EXAMPLE SO I I AM IN IN THAT
POSITION WHERE I WOULD LIKE TO
BE CAREFUL.
ON ISSUING DEBT AND TELL WE'RE
IN A LITTLE BETTER FINANCIAL.
POSITION AS NOTHING. TO SAY
ABOUT THE MERITS OR THE
NECESSITY OR THE REST THAT GOES
WITH THIS.
PROPOSAL I'M.
ON THAT.
THE CUP IS HALF FULL SIDE OF THE
EQUATION SAYING LET'S BE A
LITTLE CAUTIOUS BECAUSE IF WE DO.
GO INTO A RECESSION -- AND WE
WE'VE GOT FIGURE OUT HOW IT ALL
WORKS AND AND THAT SO THAT'S
WHERE I'M AT NOW IT'S WHILE BE
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH THRESHER
CIRCULATION WHICH LIKE TO
RESPOND.
I CAN DO IT IN MY CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH AS YOU AS YOU AS YOU.
HAVE A WONDERFUL OKAY I WOULD
SAY FIRST TO SENATOR MORE LKE I
I AS YOU KNOW APPRECIATE YOUR
FISCAL STEWARDSHIP I SHARE MANY
OF THE GOALS THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT --
UP A PROPER BALANCE SHEET AND BY
BUT I WOULD SAY THIS THAT --
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THESE
BONDS WERE DECIDING THAT THEIR
PRIORITIES?
THE PRIORITIES THAT DATE YES
THEY HAVE FIRST TAKE ON THE
GENERAL FIND OUT BECAUSE THEY
ARE IMPORTANT.
AND THE REASON THAT THESE TYPES
OF BONDS ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT -- IS BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
INSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
MATCHES THE EXPANSION THIS ISN'T
ABOUT TRYING TO BUY THE CADILLAC
IT'S ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE GOING TO OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM -- ARE DOING SO IN A
PLACE THAT'S SAFE THAT HAS
SEISMIC SAFETY BUILT INTO THEM
WHICH IS NOT THE CASE IN MANY OF
OUR BUILDINGS.
THAT HAS SAFE PLUMBING AND
ELECTRICAL ROOST THAT DON'T LEAK
SO THEY DON'T CREATE MILDEW AND
UNHEALTHY CIRCUMSTANCE -- SO I
WOULD SAY THAT IN YOUR EXAMPLE
THIS IS THE TYPE OF THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO INVEST IN EVEN IN
RAINY DAYS. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE THAT -- WE CAN
UTILIZE OUR OUR FACILITIES TO
THE MAXIMUM EXTENT AND THAT WE
CAN DO SO IN A HEALTHY HEALTHY
WAY FOR OUR STUDENTS.
AND SO I APPRECIATE -- WHY THIS
IS GOING TO CREATE AN ADDITIONAL
BURDEN ON THE GENERAL FUND I'D
SAY YES BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT?
BECAUSE IT'S A HIGH PRIORITY AND
THAT'S WHYI THINK THIS MEASURE
DESERVE TO GO FORWARD I WANTED
IN MY CLOTHES JUST THANK THE
UCLA STUDENTS.
FOR GETTING UP EARLY GO BRUINS
MY DAUGHTERS ARE BROUGHT IN AND
THEY'D BE VERY PROUD OF THE
REPRESENTATION HERE TODAY.
AND TAKE THE STUDENT ASSOCIATION
FROM UC AND FROM CSU AS WELL AS
THE SYSTEM LEADERSHIP -- THE
FACULTY AND STAFF ARE TRYING TO
WORK TOGETHER TO PUT THIS
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU I I
APPRECIATE SENSITIVITY ABOUT IT.
IN REGARD TO HOUSING -- I WILL
LOOK INTO THAT FURTHER AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND A GREATER
I THINK WE'RE GONNA ONE MORE AND
THEN I'M GONNA MAKE SOME QUICK
CLOSING COMMENTS AND WE DID YOU
WANNA MAKE COMMENTS.
YES PLEASE -- NO I I JUST WANT --
TO I I SUPPORTED THIS BILL I CAN
THE THE CAPITAL NEEDS OF THE UC
SYSTEM OR ON ENDING AND BECAUSE
WE'VE NEGLECTED THE SYSTEM FOR
SO LONG SO. FOR SUPPORT OF THE
BOND -- I ON HOUSING I'M NOT US
SAYING WHETHER IT SHOULD GO INTO
THE BOND THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE OTHER.
SERVICES AS WELL AND I KNOW THAT
WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT OF THE
DIRE NEED FOR MORE -- STUDENT
HOUSING -- THE THE AND AS THE
CEREBELLUM MENTIONED THE THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS UCC ISSUE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AS IT
IS IT'S A IT'S A MORAL FAILURE.
ON THE PART OF OUR STATE IT'S
BEYOND.
ARE UNACCEPTABLE AND WE YOU KNOW
WHAT WHEN WE DO THINGS LIKE MAKE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TUITION FREE
WHICH I SUPPORT -- IT'S GREAT
EXCEPT IT DOESN'T GET TO THE
HEART OF THE PROBLEM THAT. FOR
EXAMPLE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TUITION PALES IN COMPARISON THE
COST OF HOUSING -- AND AND WE'RE
IN AND WE'RE NOT HELPING THE
STUDENTS -- WITHOUT --
FUNDAMENTAL.
HUMAN NEED -- SO RIGHT NOW -- WE
WE DESPERATELY NEED MORE STUDENT
HOUSING.
A LOT MORE OF IT -- I BOWL NO --
APROPOS HEARING WE HELD
YESTERDAY THAT IN ALMOST 80% OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S ILLEGAL TO BUILD
STUDENT HOUSING.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
BUILD MULTI UNIT TO THE LOCAL
ZONING SO THESE ISSUES IN
APPLIED WITH EACH OTHER.
FORTUNATELY YOU SEE LIKE CS YOU --
IT IS NOT BOUND BY LOCAL ZONING --
ON LOCAL LAND USE RESTRICTIONS
AND I HOPE THAT YOU SEE --
ALTHOUGH YOU'VE COURSE ALWAYS
WANT TO BE A GOOD NEIGHBOR AND
WORK WITH -- YOUR NEIGHBORS -- I
HOPE THAT YOU SEE WILL BE BOLD
AND NOT ALLOWING LOCAL THEN BE
OPPOSITION -- TO SAY WELL YOU
CAN HAVE STUDENT HOUSING BUT IT
CAN'T BE MORE THAN THREE STORIES
TALL ARE YOU WE DON'T WANT MORE
THAN FIFTEEN UNITS THERE --
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE HERE --
AND I JUST HOPE THAT YOU SEE
WILL BE STRONG AND SAYING THAT
THE THAT THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT -- AND
EXERCISE YOUR OWN ZONING AND
LAND USE -- THOR EDDIE -- YOU
KNOW THE I THINK THE STUDENTS
SOMEONE ELSE'S THANKING
COMMANDER UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
THE STUDENTS IN GENERAL. FOR
REALLY FIGHTINGON HOUSING -- I
IF I HAVE MY INFORMATION IS
CORRECT I BELIEVE THE UCLA
STUDENTS -- BROKE AWAY FROM THE
WESTWOOD NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION -- BECAUSE THEY WERE
SICK OF IN INDIA AS ON THAT WAS
HURTING STUDENTS BECAUSE I
NEIGHBOR DECISION WAS OPPOSING
ALL SORTS OF HOUSING.
AND SO THE UCLA STUDENTS YOU
KNOW.
THANK GOD THEY DID THAT SORRY I
AM AND ALL OF THEIR STRENGTH
BROKE AWAY -- AND GOOD FOR THEM
FOR DOING THAT.
AND SO -- WILL WE NEED ALL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS
AND TO NOT LET THEM -- GET
DRAGGED.
INTO THE THIS FUNCTIONALITY OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSING POLICY AND
AND REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN FOCUS ON LEARNING -- NOT
ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
SLEEP TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WINNER I
JUST SOME QUICK CLOSING COMMENTS
AND WILL OFFER US IN A GLACIER --
A THE CLOSING PART DA SO -- IT'S
ALL GOOD LOOK AT BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS IS THE RIGHT TIME TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS.
I THINK WE HAVE TWO OPTIONS IN
THE STATE WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
PAY CASH. TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
FIX IS THAT WE NEED WHEN IT
COMES A DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON
OUR CAMPUSES I CAN SPEAK CLOSELY
TO THE ISSUES A CEASE YOU NOT
NECESSARY YOU SEE JUST BECAUSE
OF HUMBLE STAY IN CINEMA STATE.
YOU TAKE A LOOK ESPECIALLY
HUMBLE STATE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE -- IT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE.
SO.
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO PAY AS WE GO.
WE'VE BEEN ATTEMPTING TO DO THAT
WITHIN OUR GENERAL FUND.
IT IS SIMPLY IS NOT ENOUGH
BECAUSE WE HAVE IGNORED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE JUST LIKE OUR ROADS
AND BRIDGES AND HIGHWAYS --
IGNORING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR PUBLIC
FACILITIES.
I WHICH IS WHY THIS BOND IS SO
IMPORTANT.
I HEAR THE VICE CHAIR IS AND I
AGREE THAT THERE IS A CONCERN
FOR ABOUT EVERY BILLION WE PUT
ON IT SIXTY MILLION ANNUALLY IN
REGARDS.
TO PAIN DOWN THAT.
A BILLION BOND DEBT SIXTY
MILLION A YEAR AND FOR THE
GENERAL FUND.
AND THERE IS NO OTHER CHOICE.
WE CAN EITHER.
DEBATE IT [inaudible]
DISCUSS IT.
OR DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY WE ARE
HERE TODAY DUE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
LASTLY IT WOULD ACT WITH A TALK
ABOUT HOUSING AND I CAN'T ANSWER
SPEAK ON THE U. C. ISSUE BUT
JUST ON THE ISSUE -- I AM DEEPLY
CONCERNED PARTICULARLY WITH
HUMBLED STATE.
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS STUDENTS
IN FACT IT HAS THE HIHEST
NUMBERS IF NOT THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS OF HOMELESS STUDENTS
NEED TIRES HIS YOU SYSTEM -- AND
THERE IS A CRISIS IN EACH OF OUR
CAMPUSES THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS WHETHER IT IS LIVING IN
THEIR CAR COUCH SURFING.
ACTUALLY OUT IN THE STREET.
AN INABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD.
ON CAMPUS OR EVEN OFF CAMPUS
HOUSING.
I DO THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE.
A LONG TERM SPECIFIC PLAN BY
BOTH THE U. SIS WAS A CC SYSTEM
ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON
HAS INNER CAMPUSES -- AND IT MAY
MEAN ALSO A SIMILAR TYPE OF
INITIATIVE HAS BEEN PROPOSED BY
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM AROUND
HERE TODAY AND HOW WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO BUILD ADDITIONAL
UNITS.
THERE ARE SOME CAMPUSES THAT
WE'VE SEEN -- IT'S NO MISTAKE.
THAT ARE SO DESPERATE THEY'RE
GOING OUT TO PURCHASE --
APARTMENT COMPLEXES IN PETALUMA
TO BE ABLE TO ATTRACT STAFF TO
BE ABLE TO TEACH.
WE'RE AT A CRISIS POINT I DO
BELIEVE ACROSS THE STATE AND ITS
IMPACT ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN THE
UC SYSTEM AS WELL.
WHETHER IT'S ATTRACTING
RETAINING STAFF WITHIN SPECIFIC
JURISDICTIONS AND OR BEING ABLE
TO HOUSE STUDENTS I THINK THAT
WOULD WE'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
HEAR IS WHAT IS THAT NEXT STEP
WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING IN
BEING ABLE TO FIND HOUSING.
LIKE WERE ALSO ABLE -- TO FIND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON A
TURNOVER SMILE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT -- I'M WITH YA
110010% IN REGARDS THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO GO AFTER IT -- IF YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ON THAT AND THEN
ALSO -- IN REGARDS TO HOUSING
CECE'S -- WELL THE ONE COM COME
AND I WOULD MAKE IT I THINK THE
THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL WAS REALLY FOR THE ACADEMIC
BUILT BUILDINGS AND IT'S FOR
CLASSROOM SPACE.
OBVIOUSLY HOME THE HOUSING ISSUE
IS A BIG ISSUE IN THIS FIVE SAN
JUAN IT SAID.
WE ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT --
THAT THAT MIGHT TAKE A DIFFERENT
EFFORT -- I DO THINK THAT THE
THE CHALLENGE OF PLEASE PUSH
BACK ON ME.
IF YOU THINK I'M INCORRECT IN
THIS.
THE WAY WE ARE TRYING TO BE ABLE
TO HANDLE IT.
WE JUST CAN'T THAT THE THE FUNDS
ARE NOT THERE WHETHER IT IS
WITHIN THE SPECIFIC UNIVERSE
THAT THE CAMPUS ITSELF OR WITHIN
THE SYSTEM. TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
THE NECESSARY HOUSING THERE TO
MEET DEMAND [inaudible]
AND THAT'S THE CHALLENGE I THINK
WE HAPPEN THAT'S WHY I THINK WE
NEED A VERY SPECIFIC PLAN WHEN
IT COMES TO HOUSING.
UP FOR BOTH THIS ISSUE SYSTEM IN
THE UC SYSTEM ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR IT.
BECAUSE I I UNDERSTAND THAT
TRYING TO LOSE.
YOUR INPUT NOT TRYING TO PUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH BUT TRYING
TO BE A FOCUS IN ON IT NO THAT
IS AN ISSUE.
BUT REALLY THE ONLY WAY THAT'S
GOING TO SOLVE THIS IS.
MONEY IN THE SYSTEM TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD WOULD THAT BE -- RACK
YEAH WE WE NEED THE FUNDS IN
ORDER TO BUILD AND MAKE IT
AFFORDABLE.
I THINK THE OPERATING FUNDS ARE
OPERATING FUNDS AS WELL OR EVEN
IF WE BUILT IT.
HAZARD PAY FOR THEM TO EAT.
UTILITIES FOR FOR THAT FACILITY.
SO LOOKING AT OF GRANTS AND
SUBSIDIES ELSEWHERE AN ONGOING
BASIS IS THE CHALLENGE IS
ANOTHER PART OF THE CHALLENGE.
AND THEN I I THINK -- YOU ALSO
ARE.
SUFFERING FROM I I I TRACKED IN
pBECAUSE OF HOUSING AS WELL -- IN
WERE SEEN SOME INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE BEING
ADVANCED RIGHT BUT IT'S COMMON
SIXTY HUNDRED UNITS AT A TIME --
IN THERE'S A BIT OF A WAVE YOUR
COMMENT ON THAT AT ALL.
WELL WHAT IS SO FOR CINEMA
FORTUNATELY THE CAMPUS WAS ABLE
TO PURCHASE A HOME AT LUMINA
YEAH.
PROPERTY OF BUT BUT IT'S A
CHALLENGE ESPECIALLY WHERE THERE
BEEN FIRES IN AREAS YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF HOUSING FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF AND AND
STUDENTS THAT CAN AFFORD IT IN
IN ADDITION TO THE HOMELESS SO
IT IS A CHALLENGE IN CERTAIN
AREAS AND IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IS SUCH A HIGH COST AREA IT'S
HARD TO FIGURE OUT AND COME UP
WITH A MASTER PLAN.
BUT I THINK IT IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO WORK WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS FIND OUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO WORK WITH OUR
CITIES.
AND UNDERSTAND THE ROAD MAP FOR
YOU KNOW HERE THEIR FUNDING IS
AN IS OUR ABILITY TO WORK
TOGETHER ON SOME PROJECT.
AND I THINK AGAIN -- NOT TRYING
TO DICTATE WHERE YOU ALL THINK
NEED TO GO BUT I DO THINK THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A SPECIFIC
PLAN ON HOUSING.
WITH A MAJOR FOCUS ON STUDENTS.
ALSO ON FACULTY WITH BOTH
SYSTEMS AND WHAT THAT'S GONNA
TAKE FINANCIALLY THAT'S GONNA
HAVE TO BE A DECISION THEY WERE
AT THE MOVE FOR WITH A SIMILAR
INITIATIVE. TO WHAT'S IN YOUR
LASERS ARE PROPOSING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU NOT VERY GRATEFUL --
THAT WILL TURN OVER TO SEND IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH BY THE WAY I
DID MORE TALKING AND HE DID SO --
WILL TURN OVER CENTER GLAZER FOR
A A CLOSING COMMENT -- DID TO
CHAIR -- ACQUIRE THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR THIS
MEASURE -- IT'S CERTAINLY THIS
PADDLE PROBABLY HAS GREATER
EXPERTISE IN LEADERSHIP IN THE
AREA OF HOUSING THAN ANY
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE -- AND I
THINK THAT THE THE THAT YOU'VE
STIMULATED IS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
INTEGRATE -- THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS IN REGARD TO HOUSING IT
WITHOUT THE THE BROADER STATE
CONVERSATION THAT'S GOING ON IN
THE HEARINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKING PLACE AND I WOULD WELCOME.
THE INCLUSION OF THAT SPECIFIC
SUBJECT IN THE IN FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS IN HEARINGS THAT
SHOULD BE IT SHOULD GO FORWARD --
BIGGER THAN THE INSTITUTION BUT
I THINK THE INSTITUTIONS CAN
COME AND TALK ABOUT IT AND GET
GET THAT FEEDBACK AND AND SHARE
AND AND FIGURE OUT WAYS TO MOVE
FORWARD -- AND DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THIS CAN'T HAPPEN WITHIN WHAT'S
BEFORE YOU BUT WHAT I THINK WILL
BRING IT BACK AND I'LL HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
BUT IN CLOSING LET ME JUST SAY
THAT.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT ONLY PUTS
IT ON THE BALLOT FOR THE VOTERS
TO DECIDE.
WE CAN'T MAKE THAT DECISION TO
BORROW HERE SO THAT THEY'LL BE A
ROBUST CONVERSATION.
ABOUT DEATH AND COSTS -- AS WELL
AS NEEDED -- GOING FORWARD IF
THIS MEASURE -- IS PLACED ON THE
BALLOT BUT FOR TOO LONG WE'VE
ALLOWED CLASSROOMS LIBRARIES
RESEARCH LABS IN OUR CAMPUS THE
FALLEN DISREPAIR.
THERE'S A BIG CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT IS A LONG TERM COSTS.
OF BOTH AND AT FUTURE ADDITIONAL
COSTS AND AND IN TERMS OF
STUDENT SUCCESS.
THIS BOND WILL PROVIDE A MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENT IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY ENGLISH THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
AGAIN A STARTED -- I'LL INTO AS
I STARTED IT YOU BEEN INCREDIBLY
PASSION ABOUT THIS -- IN YOU ARE
PUTTING YOUR EFFORT WHERE YOUR
WORDS HAVE BEEN I AM VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
WHEN I SAY THANK YOU TO THE TEAM
FROM THE C. C. SYSTEM.
FOR ALL THE ENERGY AND EFFORT
THAT'S BEEN PUT INTO THIS AS
WELL AS THE UC SYSTEM WERE VERY
GREAT FOR THE HERE AND FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP -- AND THAT'S SEE IF
WE HAVE A MOTION TO BE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY A SENATOR BALLIN SP.
FOURTEEN WITH WITH WITH THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT HOUSING -- HERE IN THE
FUTURE SINNER.
IT ALL RIGHT LIKE SEE THUMBS UP --
IN THIS IS THE MOTION IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS
MISS LANCHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI.
I'M MORE LOCKED.
MORE LOCKED NOBEL.
I HURTS BIRD FOR TARO NELSON
WIENER.
WIENER WE ARE CURRENTLY GEORGIA
THREE ONE VOTE WE'RE GONNA HOLD
ROLL THING AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO SENATOR MORALES
CENTER MORALE IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING SP -- FIVE SIX TWO
AND IT'S ALL ON ISSUES OF
MEDICARE FOR ALL AND HEALTH CARE
I'M KIDDING -- IT'S ON PROPERTY
TAXATION -- IN -- IN REGARDS. TO
A TAX THAT WE WERE GRATEFUL FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS.
THE GOOD SENATORS HERE.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER
[inaudible]
ANDREA.
IN YOUR OWN WE WELCOME THE GOOD
SENATOR DO COMMITTEE.
WELL THANK YOU -- JUST GIVE US --
ONE MINUTE MR SENATOR AND WE'LL
HAVE.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS SENATOR YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TODAY -- ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK SIR SO WE
OFFER YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE US WITH A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR COMMENTS AS YOU
DO A BI PARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORKCENTRE MORALE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK CAN I VOTE.
GOODNESS THERE WE GO WITH THE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GO TO MAKE.
ONE WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
MORLOCK CINEMA REAL IF YOU WANT
TO JUST GIVE US A CLUE DON'T
VERSION PLEASE LIKE AND I'M
GONNA HAVE J. R. TOO BUT I'LL
GIVE YOU A BRIEF BASICALLY.
I THANK YOU -- CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BOB -- SP FIVE SIXTY TWO WELL OF
COURSE HELP THE VETERANS THOSE
WHO HAVE FOUGHT FOR SINCE SERVED
OUR COUNTRY WELL OF PROTECTING
THE FAIRNESS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
EXEMPTION.
FROM TWO OH TWO TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND AND THEY
JUST IT'LL HELP I THINK HE
ACTUALLY INCREASED -- THE
ABILITY A LOT OF IT TURNS AROUND.
ANSEL INCREASE THEIR ABILITY TO
BUY AND KEEP THEIR PAYMENTS LOW
AND SO WITH ME TODAY IS J. R.
WILSON PRESIDENT THE DELTA
VETERANS GROUP.
AND SO IF YOU'D LIKE.
TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY --
MY NAME IS JAY ARE WILSON I'M A
UNITED STATES ARMY DISABLED
VETERAN -- I AM THE PRESIDENT
AND FOUNDER OF DELTA VETERANS
GROUP AS WELL AS THE PAST STATE
COMMANDER FOR THE DISABLED
AMERICAN VETERANS.
AS THE PRESIDENT OF DELTA
VETERANS GROUP WE PROVIDE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY WITH ITS HOMELESS
VETERANS STAND DOWN STAND DOWN
ON THE DELTA WE SEE A LOT OF
VETERANS.
THAT ARE AT THE RISK OF BEING
HOMELESS EITHER THEY'RE SLEEPIG
ON THEIR FRIENDS -- SURE THERE
MY PARENTS HOUSE -- WORTH SP
FIVE SIXTY TWO THAT KIND OF
BRINGS THAT BERRIER UP SO THEY
CAN GET INTO HOME OWNERSHIP.
I MYSELF ALSO AM A RECIPIENT OF
THE EXEMPTION AS I AM A 100%
SERVICE CONNECTED VETERAN -- ME
AND MY LOVELY WIFE HAVE TWO
CHILDREN.
A TEN YEAR OLD AND A SEVENTEEN
MONTH OLD AS YOU WELL KNOW THAT
IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN.
THE PRICE OF RAISING CHILDREN
DOESN'T GET ANY CHEAPER -- AS
YOU ALSO KNOW ARE DISABLED
AMERICAN OR OR DAR VA
COMPENSATION -- ALSO HAS A COLD
INCREASE HORRID DOESN'T MATCH
THE INCREASE IN OUR IN OUR
PROPERTY ASSESSED VALUES -- SO
JUST FOR EXAMPLE MY MORTGAGE
PAYMENT WENT FROM SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY ONE TO EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A LOT BUT
WHEN YOUR INCOME IS SET.
ANY OF THAT ADJUSTMENT IN YOUR
INCOME MEANS LIFE CHANGING.
THINGS AS WELL AS AS AR AS AS
ALSO BRINGING UP KIDS -- AS WELL
SO I'M I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF BUT
ALSO THE DISABLED VETERANS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE DISABLED
AMERICAN VETERANS ALTHOUGH IT'S
A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION WE DO
HAVE A STATE ORGANIZATION HERE
AS WELL WITH A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS -- IN WE AS YOU KNOW WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF SUPPORT AS
FAR AS A DISABLED AMERICAN
VETERANS SO I RELY ON THAT
LETTER SUPPORT WON'T GO AHEAD
AND READ IT AND TODAY -- BUT I
DO WANT TO THINK -- SENATOR
MORALE FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL.
HIS STRONG SUPPORT FOR VETERANS --
THE LIVING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A PROUD
SUPPORTER OF SP FIVE SIXTY TWO
AND I'M ASKING YOU FOR A VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
WILSON WERE GREAT FOR THE
HEARING COMMITTED WE ARE EVEN
MORE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SERVICER
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR COMING HERE AND I CAN
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE CASKETS
SO -- YEAH WATCH OUT -- IN THE
BREAK WHILE I QUICKLY SO --
WOULD LIKE TO GET IT NOW WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME.
AS WELL AS YOUR ORGANIZATION WE
WELCOME YOU WERE ON SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME.
A GOOD MORNING TIMOTHY BURR ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CESSATION
OF VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
WE'D LIKE TO BE A HAVING A LAST
CALL FOR SUPPORT LAST CALL GOOD
MORNING SIR GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS CORNELIA'S RONALD
ARTS I'M A PROUD VENDOR WHO ARE
PROUD MEMBER OF THE THE THE AV.
AND I FIRMLY SUPPORT THIS THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
ATTENDING TO A WERE GREAT FOR
YOUR HERE.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
THIS TIME LAST CALL.
NOW  WOULD LIKE THERE TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU COULD PLEASE RISE AND COME
FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY THE VICE
CHAIR THAT DAY TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE.
MR BASHER -- JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION CENTER MORALE WITH THAT.
FOR EVERY BEING A FORMER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR 92% OF THE REVENUES
FOR THE COUNTY.
CAME FROM PROPERTY TAXES SO I'M
WONDERING [inaudible]
IF.
FIVE IF COUNTIES CITIES AND
SCHOOLS ARE GOING.
TO BE SUBSIDIZING THIS.
IMPORTANT BENEFIT I HAVE YOU
GOTTEN THEIR SUPPORT.
IS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
PROBABLY GOING.
TO TAKE THE THE BIGGEST.
NO THERE THERE THAT MAKE ALL YOU
KNOW THAT YES THERE'S GOING TO
BE.
EVAN FLOW ON THAT COURSE IT'S
GOING TO OPEN UP THE ABILITY AND
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE FOR VETERANS
TO BUY HOMES TO SELL THEY'LL RE
COOP -- ON PURCHASES OF HOMES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT'S GOING
TO BE AT SO IT'S HARD TO FIGURE
IT BUT I I THINK IT'LL BE GOOD%
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS MORE
VETERANS IN ANY OTHER STATE DOES
IN AMERICA.
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS VICE CHAIR
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
GENERAL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AND THANK. EIGHT FOOT FOR YOUR
HELP WANT TO SUPPORT OUR
VETERANS GRATEFUL.
THEY PROTECT OUR COUNTRY THANK
YOU ABSOLUTE GENERAL YOU'VE BEEN
AN ABSOLUTE CHAMPION ON THIS AND
WERE SO APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
WORK.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THIS IS HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
SP FIVE SIXTY TWO IS A DO PASS A
VETERANS AFFAIRS MOORE'S MOTION.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
FROM THE VICE CHAIR PASTE YOUR
MORLOCK DESIGN CHESTER ROLL CALL
PLEASE CHOIR HI WHY I'M MORE A
LOT.
WELL LIKE I BUILT.
BILL I HEARD HER.
HELLO NELSON WIENER.
WIENER ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE FOUR ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
UNTIL WE HAVE -- OUR REMAINING
MEMBERS.
THERE IS A GEM AND WE ARE NOW --
ON THE HUNT FOR SENATOR CAFIERO
CENTER HOW HEROES ARE LAST TILL
THE DAY.
SHE'S WRAPPING UP.
SO SENATOR BELL -- WE HAVE A NEW
MEMBER OF OUR COMMITTEE -- WE
HAVE A CENTER WE I AND A SINNER
WEINER IS A NEW SENATOR LARA --
AS FAR AS THE HE'S HERE EASIER.
WELL SAID ZERO SO IS A BELL A
SOONER MORE LOCK WE HAVE A
TRADITION HERE WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE NUMBERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
EXPLAIN. TO THE GOOD CENTER FOR
SERVICES GO THAT TRADITION IS
CENTER WHAT.
WE HAVE A GREAT [inaudible]
PROGRAM [inaudible]
WE ASK ONE OF OUR MEMBERS TO
DANCE -- THAT.
THE FIRST PERSON IN EVERY YEAR.
YEAH [inaudible]
WIRE [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T REMEMBER THAT TRADITION --
THANK YOU.
THE OF WALKING OVER THE PROTONS
OFFICE AT THIS HEARING TEST TO
BE REMOVED FROM THE THIRTY BELL --
ISABEL DOES HAVE A TALENT
[inaudible]
YOU DO.
HE CAN -- YOU CAN SING SOME
IRISH.
LATER WE WILL RESIGN. SEVEN IS
HERE HE HE'S IS VERY TO GO MY
RIGHT.
IS IT AGAIN AS HEAD [inaudible]
AND SPECIAL.
THERE ARE SEVEN DIDN'T BEGIN.
THE SKILLS OF THE IRISH JIG --
THE SENATOR SO -- WHICH YES IT
WAS.
ONCE A YEAR IT IS A ONCE A YEAR
TRADITION IT'S IT'S VERY TRUE.
WELL WE'RE HOPING THAT A CUT WE
ARE CAN GET HERE QUICK.
BECAUSE IT'S GETTING AWKWARD.
ALRIGHT WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU
HERE IN A FEW MOMENTS
.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE WOMAN
THE MYTH THE LEGEND CENTER COVER
HEROES HERE.
THE COVER HERO -- WE'RE VERY
WORRIED AS SENATOR WEINER.
IT WAS GOING TO START SINGING --
IT TO BE ABLE TO DO SOME --
BRIEF ENTERTAINMENT -- AND WE
YOU SAVED US [inaudible]
YES.
THEN WINNER -- WHAT WE GONNA
SING HERE TODAY -- SOME DONNA
SUMMERS -- HEY THERE YOU GO I
LIKE BUT I DID HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY SO I GUESS.
IT'S OVER.
THAT'S RIGHT ABSOLUTELY WELL
SENATOR BEER WE WELCOME YOU --
TO TO COMMITTEE ON SP TWENTY SIX
FOCUSING IN ON WORKING FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY ON CHILD CARE AND
THAT TAX CREDIT.
AS IN A CAREER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR TEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- I'M HAPPY TO
PRESENT IS B. TWENTY SIX WHICH
WOULD MAKE THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
AND DEPENDENT CARE EXPENSES
CREDIT REFUNDABLE SO THAT LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME WORKING
FAMILIES COULD BENEFIT FROM THE
CREDIT. TO ASSIST WITH THEIR
CHILD CARE EXPENSES.
THIS IS A WORKING FAMILY TAX
CREDIT. TO QUALIFY THE TAX FILER
MAY SHOW THE INCURRED CHILDCARE
EXPENSES IN ORDER TO WORK.
THE CREDIT ALLOWS TAXPAYERS WITH
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME BELOW A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
REDUCE THEIR TAX LIABILITY BY A
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR ELIGIBLE
CHILD CARE EXPENSES.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE STATE
MADE THE CREDIT NON REFUNDABLE
DUE TO BUDGET SHORTFALLS.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT FAMILIES
WITH INCOMES BELOW FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS RECEIVE NO
BENEFIT BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE
A TAX LIABILITY?
WHEN THE CREDIT WAS REFUNDABLE
THE POOREST FAMILIES BENEFITED
ASSISTING THEM TO MEET THEIR
BASIC SIX EXPENSES LIKE FOOD
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION?
WE KNOW THAT THE COST OF CHILD
CARE IS EXPENSIVE AND AN
INCREASING BURDEN ON
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES.
LACK OF ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE IS A HUGE PROBLEM AND
WE NEED MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS AND
THIS IS JUST ONE OF THEM.
RESTORING THE CHILD AND
DEPENDENT CARE CARE TAX CREDIT
TO BENEFIT EVERY FAMILY THAT
QUALIFIES WILL BRING EQUITY TO
OUR CURRENT TAX SYSTEM SO
BASICALLY IF YOU MADE BETWEEN
FIFTY AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET MONEY BACK
BUT IF YOU'RE UNDER FIFTY YOU
DON'T WHICH IS REALLY INVERSE OF
WHAT WHAT WE PROBABLY SHOULD DO.
MAKING THE TAX CREDIT REFUNDABLE
AGAIN WE'LL PUT MONEY BACK IN
THE POCKETS OF FAMILIES THAT
NEED IT THE MOST.
THOSE EARNING UNDER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR EYE BUT TODAY IN
HERE WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS KELLY
GRASS SUCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK.
THINK OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND AT
YOU AS TO THE RIGHT WHEN THE
MOST IMPORTANT SO WE CAN DO FOR
WOMEN WERE IN FAMILY SO.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR EFFORT.
WELCOME THE COMMITTEE THE
FORESHORES MA'AM YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES.
THANK YOU.
EMPTORIS MCGUIRE NUMBERS AT THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY MOVE THE
MICROPHONE UP A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
MYSELF BUT MAYBE THANK YOU --
FOR LET ME BUY IT WITH WITH YOU
TODAY.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK HAS
SUPPORTED OUR MEMBER RESOURCE ME
FOR ALL AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND WHILE WE PLAY A LEADING ROLE
IN HELPING CREATE AN AWARENESS
ABOUT CHILDCARE ISSUES.
ALSO LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
ISSUES ARISE.
WELL OUR PURPOSE FORTY YEARS AGO
WAS TO CONNECT FAMILIES TO
CHILDCARE THAT MEETS THEIR NEEDS
TODAY AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS
ARE IN OURS ADVOCATE FOR THE
ABILITY OF FAMILIES TO ACCESS
THE COST OF CARE.
WHERE THEY NEEDED WHEN THEY NEED
IT AND WITHOUT THE BARRIER OF
COST?
YET A MAJOR BARRIER TO USING
LICENSED CHILDCARE IS THE COST
ACCORING TO OUR RECENT RELEASE
RELEASE CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE
PORTFOLIO THE AVERAGE COST OF A
CHILDCARE CENTER.
IS RANGING BETWEEN ELEVEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND A CHILD CARE CENTER.
THE AVERAGE COST OF FAMILY
CHILDCARE IS RANGING BETWEEN
SEVEN THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED ON AVERAGE
CHILDCARE CAN TAKE UP TO ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF THE FAMILY'S INCOME
THAT'S OUR MONTHLY BUDGET.
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES FACE A
MUCH HEAVIER BURDEN PAYING FOR
CHILDCARE.
YET CHILDCARE IS ONLY ABLE
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ABLE TO PAY
IN ABOUT ONE IN NINE ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN FOR CHILDCARE SUBSIDIES.
A FAMILY WHOSE INCOME ELIGIBLE
FOR SUBSIDY BUT DOES NOT RECEIVE
ONE THEY COULD END UP PAYING
OVER 40% OF THEIR INCOME THAT
THEY'RE EARNING.
THOSE SAME FAMILIES ARE LIKELY
TO QUALIFY FOR RE FRIEND FROM
THE CHILD AND DEPENDENT CARE
EXPENSES CREDIT SHOULD AS B.
TWENTY SIX BECOME A LOT.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE UP A
SIGNIFICANT LOST GROUND BY
REINSTATING THE RENT REFUND
ABILITY OF THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT.
WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL WILL HAVE
A REAL IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA
FAMILY STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR
THEIR CHILD CARE EXPENSES AND
THE TAX YEAR TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT WHEN IT WAS STILL
REFUNDABLE.
IT PROVIDED OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS IN REFUNDS TO CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND WHILE THAT MAY NOT
SEEM LIKE A HUGE AMOUNT THOSE
LITTLE BIT.
HELP TO MAKE UP THAT FAMILIES
ABILITY TO PAY FOR THINGS SO
WHILE THIS TAX CREDIT MAY NOT
PAY FOR YOU KNOW WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE PAYING OUT
IN THE YEAR.
THAT TAX CREDIT WHEN IT DOES
COME IN HELP SET FAMILY TO FREE
UP OTHER EXPENSES WHEN WE TALK
TO FAMILIES ABOUT AFFORDING
CHILDCARE WE HELP THEM TO THINK
ABOUT THEIR FOOD COST THEIR
UTILITY COSTS FOR TRANSPORTATION
COSTS.
AND A REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT
COULD BE JUST WHAT THEY NEED AT
THE RIGHT TIME SO THAT THEY CAN
KEEP THEIR HEADS ABOVE WATER.
WELL -- ONCE -- SB TWENTY SIX
WILL SUPPORT WORKING FAMILIES TO
CONTINUE TO DO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS WHILE ALLOWING THEM
TO KEEP THEIR CHILDREN.
IN THE CHILD CARE SETTING THAT
THEY KNOW AND THAT THEY LOVE
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE NOT KEEPING
THEIR HEADS ABOVE WATER THEY MAY
BE MAKING ALTERNATIVE SOLUTIONS.
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA TODAY
HAVE TO MAKE CHOICES SO THAT
THEY CAN GET TO WORK SO THAT
THEY CAN KEEP A ROOF ABOVE THEIR
HEADS.
SO THEY PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
ABOUT ONE MINUTE.
SO WE URGE YOU TO STAY ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH NICE JOB
IN WE TRULY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK ON THIS. FOR A GROUP OF
YOUR EFFORT IN WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR THANK YOU.
WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS
TIME.
YOU DON'T MIND SEEING YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION THOSE IN SUPPORT.
NOW LIKE BETTER TRANSITION TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR A POST IS BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME.
HEARING TEEN NINE IS IT THERE'S
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS THE
DEW PASTOR PREPARATIONS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE CENTER COPIER -- MAKE
A CLOSE RESPECTED RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NEIGHBORS.
THERE GREAT JOB I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN HUSTLING BACK AND FORTH
TODAY AND SEE NEW HAVING GOT A
COMEDIAN BACK SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JUNK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MISSING CHESTER ROLL
CALL PLEASE CHOIR HI.
BELLE.
BELLE HEART HURTS BIRD
[inaudible]
HI.
LADIES IN GERMAN THAT IS A THREE
ZERO WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN -- WE ARE MISSING MISTER
TITLE IN MISTER HERZBERG MISTER
NIELSEN IS NOT HERE TODAY SO --
WE ARE GOING TO PUT THE ALL CALL
OUT -- IN WILL KEEP THIS ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH AND A
CAREER THANK YOU BUT IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WHAT WOULD THAT DO WE
HAVE TO DO IS -- HOLD FOR SIXTY
SECONDS THIS MAKE SURE THAT EACH
OF YOU ARE ON EACH OF THE BILLS
BEFORE YOU ROLL OUT -- AND THEN
WE'LL OPEN THE ROLE IF NECESSARY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE HAVE.
SENT HER TITLE.
I DON'T KNOW.
FIGURED OUR TITLE IS -- ABLE TO
BLESS US WITH THEIR PRESENCE
HERE TODAY YOU [inaudible]
HI DAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WINNER.
THERE YOU GO.
WELL GOOD MORNING.
HELLO JOHN.
I GET THIS ONE MINUTE WE'LL GET
GOING.
ALRIGHT LADIES IN GERMAN HERE WE
GO WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO OUR
CONSENT FIRST ITEM NUMBER THREE
SP TWO FORTY TWO THIS IS A DO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
IT'S NOT JUST A CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A FOUR ZERO VOTE MISSING CHESTER.
FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR HERTZ
BERG WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE FILE ITEM ONE IS S. B.
FOURTEEN IS HAS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ONE
VOTE CHAIRMAN UNITE MISSING
CHESTER. FOR ONE VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP ROLE OPEN.
A FILE AND NUMBER TWO SB TWENTY
SIX IS HAS A MOTION OF DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A THREE ZERO VOTE.
GERALDINE I MISSED LANCHESTER
TARO. FOUR ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN WE'RENOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP.
FOUR FIFTY ONE AT THIS CURRENTLY
HAS A THREE ZERO VOTE WITH THE
MOTION DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
MISS LANE CHESTER.
I FOUR IS ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN FOR MISTER
HERZBERG AND FINALLY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP.
FIVE SIXTY TWO THIS IS A MOTION
OF A DO PASS THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR
ZERO VOTE.
ISN'T JESTER TITLE.
HER TITLE IS IN AND SHE'S READY
TO ROLL AT FIVE ZERO VOTES THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER HER TITLE
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
MY GOODNESS
-- JACKSON.
IF THERE'S ANYTHING IN THE
FUTURE.
THE WILLIAMS CASH NOW I GET A
LATEST GERMANY IS HERE AND HE'S
READY TO ROLL.
WE HAVE CENTER HERTZBERG EXTRA
FROM THE GREATER ALLEY REGION --
CENTERS FOR HE SAID A CRAZY
MORNING JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW I
REPRESENT AND EYES.
AND THEN EYES AS A POPULATION
LARGER THAN SOUTH BEND INDIANA
MAYOR PETE.
WE HAVE PRESIDENT HERTZBERG HERE.
A BROTHER VISITED HERE YOU HEARD
IT HERE FIRST IN THIS COMMITTEE
THAT'S RIGHT LADIES YEAH WE'RE
GOING TO BE OPENING UP ALL OF
OUR ITEMS WE'RE GONNA START WITH
CONSENT -- TO IS B. TWO FOUR TO
DO PAST APPROPRIATIONS MISSING
CHESTER.
HI. SIX ZERO WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE THAT BILL IT IS OUT WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP FOURTEEN DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ONE VOTE
MISSING CHESTER.
HI. FIVE ONE VOTE THAT'S FINAL
THE BILL IS THAT WE'RE CLOSE THE
ROLE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWENTY
SIX TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO VOTE MISSILE
IN CHESTER.
HI. FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP FOUR FIFTY ONE TO PASS
AS A MANAGER PREPARATIONS
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE MISSING CHESTER.
HI. FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS
THAT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER FIVE FIVE
SIXTY TWO DO PASS TO VETERANS
AFFAIRS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE MISSING CHESTER.
HI. SIX ZERO MISTER PRESIDENT IS
ROLLING ON OUT.
HE'S GOING TO NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
IOWA -- THANK YOU SO MUCH IT
HURTS -- FOR WE WILL SEE
EVERYBODY THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND
WILL BE GOING TO ABOUT FOUR
THIRTY IN THE AFTERNOON NEXT
WEEK ACCORDING TO WHAT MR NOW MY
RIGHT MR NOW.
YES HE'S EXCITED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED I STRUGGLING
CHESTER